helpful bus with Bobby kalila and George
hello the tiger belly crew I'm a big fan
of the podcast actually the only podcast
I listen to I emailed you because I came
across this YouTube video involving an
interracial couple and I wanted to hear
Bobby 'uncle Alice opinion on this a
Korean man Justin is in a relationship
with a Sudanese Filipino few female
Sarah Justin brought Sarah to meet his
parents unannounced the parents did not
approve especially the mother it would
not let Sarah into the house nor talk to
her in my opinion we live in a great
diverse society that has many different
cultures religions and race definitely
in our generation we were raised in a
multicultural society it allowed us to
appreciate the difference between
cultures provide us with an open eye
perspective to other parts of the world
and engage in a diverse group as a
second generation immigrant I am very
accepting to interracial relationships
the question is when Bobby first
introduced Klaus parents what was the
reaction I want to say this how exciting
were they it's the guy's fault the
Korean guy yeah I'll tell you why you
you think that my brother and I right
have a little liberal parents know their
traditional Koreans that have fucked-up
views about society right
we hate Filipino we you know they're all
growing out we hate Indian only Korean
number one right finger yeah people
should not be President
yeah that kind of [ __ ] yeah right and
you look at your parents you go you if
you don't change that right now I'm
never talking to you again that's
[ __ ] crazy and then they realized
through years of us just being like you
know being gays fine okay it's fine then
right you you train them you eat you're
an extension of you your parents in and
if like if if my parent if my dad said
I'm gonna vote for Trump right it's just
like alright well we're done I'm done
they know that no they're gonna they're
gonna they're gonna abide by the rules
set out for us
they're all men are created equally
there's no difference right being gay is
an abomination there you just born that
way because a [ __ ] right and this guy
didn't train his parents because let me
say this right now if I brought my
[ __ ] girlfriend this [ __ ] you know
mean island [ __ ] right his I look to my
house mom's kalila or she don't go on
side while I'm not going inside and I'll
see you later and Whitley get a hotel
room and I'd eat her [ __ ] in that hotel
room right I think you know what you're
right because I think that you told her
I was Filipino yeah you didn't tell her
I was half yeah because when she saw me
she goes all I thought you were Filipino
but you're so pretty
yeah and as if like a Filipino couldn't
otherwise be I was like oh thing yeah
now if she was ugly that's a different
that's that's different awesome
knighting or [ __ ] but you know you're
like here's what it not ugly what I'm
saying is is that my parents here's what
here's what they want right they don't
care necessarily about race you know or
they care more about their heart what
their heart is like so it's like when
kalila was helping my dad with his
medical stuff waking up early and really
trying to engage with them they get what
that is and they go oh this is a good
person you know my my ex-girlfriend
Christine she's a nice girl and I'm not
saying anything bad she's married now
I'm very happy for her
but she was a little standoffish with my
parents and they were fine with her but
they they didn't fall in love with her
like they fell in love with kalila they
really love kalila like an extension
they loved Sarah because Sarah is much
like kalila in that way I think that
your mom likes easy people yes she likes
people who are like just go to the
living room squat on the floor low
maintenance yeah I know Sarah seems like
she was probably very similar she's very
similar in that way Malone's yeah but
but they were again there was nothing
with Christina you know she was a cool
girl you know they just wasn't that
connection you know I think this guy if
I was that guy I would just be like well
I'll see you later
mom and dad and just move on with his
life I know it's difficult to do and I
know that sounds crazy but to me I it's
embarrassing it's like one you know I
just talked to white dude my parents
voted for Trump oh but that just would
not happen with my parents because you
know what if you went home and then you
saw like an old like ballot or whatever
like a stub like let's say they had
receipts and you saw that the all this
time they'd be like Bobby we didn't vote
we didn't vote but they actually voted
for Trump like what would what would
happen after that well I would probably
go did you vote for Trump and they would
say oh yeah okay we did we did right
okay I'm fine with that
yeah really yeah um you guys don't have
cell phones anymore by the way you can't
communicate with the outside world no
because I pay for their cell phones yeah
so that's cut off yeah okay and I got in
the $4,000 to send you every month that
done oh yeah bye
that's how and that that sounds crazy
right yeah yeah I know it sounds crazy
but I think I believe that I stand by it
I don't think I'm going I don't think
you could do what cut your parents off I
don't think so either
I think everything you talk about I'm
the same way with mine let me think let
me think let me think
revisit revisit yeah ed maybe you're
right
you love them too much it's a little one
well um I guess Luther's lose a
girlfriend then cut the girl phone off I
don't know what else is her
[Music]